there's a particular ethos in u.s.
culture especially in entertainment and
marketing culture that very much appeals
to people as individuals that you don't
have to be devoted or sub servant
subservient to anything else
there is no larger good than your own
good and your own happiness and that in
the book it's best I can recall
characters have become drug drug drug
addicts there is a form that the root in
English of addict is the Latin not a
cherry which means which means religious
devotion if it was an attribute of
beginning monks I think that there's
there's an element in the book in which
various people are are living out
something that I think it is true which
is that we all we all worship and we all
have a religious impulse we we can
choose to an extent what we worship but
the myth that we worship nothing and
give ourselves away to nothing is simply
simply sets us up to give ourselves away
to something different for instance
pleasure or drugs or the idea of having
a lot of money in being able to buy my
stuff or in the tennis academy it's it's
somewhat different it's devotion to an
athletic pursuit that requires a certain
amount of sacrifice and discipline but
is nevertheless an individual sport and
one is trying one is one is trying to
get ahead as an individual I doubt this
makes very much sense but whatever
whatever the conditions of hopelessness
you're talking about at least at least
in at least in in if and it just have to
do I think with with
with an AI with an American idea and not
a universal one but one that I think
kids get exposed to very early that that
you are the most important and what you
want is the most important and the your
job in life is to is to gratify your own
desires that that's a little crude to
say it that way but in but in but in
fact it's it's something of the ideology
here and it's it's certainly the
ideology that's perpetrated by a
television and advertising and
entertainment and the economy thrives on
it